from the disaster Slam Dunk Contest to
settling the weatherman beef basketball
seems to be a new part of the culture at
ymh especially after last week's
one-on-one challenge between Booth boy
Annie and your mom's house president
Ryan Hall a game to 11 that included
some insane Stakes the deal was if
anyone Ryan would become his personal
assistant for a weekend in Vegas and
he'd receive a full hair transplant but
if he lost and he would have to endure
the brutal consequence of receiving an
enema on camera there was lots of funny
content during this game involving the
ref Danny Brown and Josh Potter's
play-by-play nadav's thousand dollar bet
and of course coach Tom Segura who we
all know has plenty of basketball
experience